let's continue talking about this CIA
briefing that Republican senators
recently received Senator Lindsey Graham
who's a Republican from South Carolina
he came out of this briefing which were
going to outline probably in more detail
tomorrow I don't think we'll have time
for it today and he said very simply and
very plain in simple terms the Saudi
Prince Mohammed bin Salman ordered the
killing period so Graham went in he was
briefed by CIA director Gina Haspel and
he came out saying there's just no doubt
about it whatsoever you might remember
that this is the same Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham who jumped the shark
completely during the Brett Kavanaugh
hearings recently a few weeks months I
don't even have lost complete track of
time but it happened this year for sure
during the sexual assault Supreme Court
hearings for Brett Kavanaugh he came out
like a freight train after a brief
recess in the hearings to start yelling
and screaming like an unbalanced person
that the hearings were the most unfair
thing he had ever seen in politics I
mean truly delusional hyperbole
interestingly we now have video of
Lindsey Graham straight-up just
admitting to being a hypocrite after the
CIA briefing Graham I'm going to set up
the video for you Graham was asked about
the comments last week from Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo and Secretary of
Defense Jim mattis who both said listen
we don't have any evidence that Mohammed
bin Salman was actually involved that
directly contradicts what the CIA has
found and what the CIA has said to the
senators that it briefed and Graham just
says straight up in the video I'm gonna
play for you I'm a hypocrite he says if
Pompeo and mattis were Democrats I'd
accuse them of being in the pocket of
Saudi Arabia but they're not they're
Republicans so I'm gonna assume that
they're acting in good faith it is zero
chance zero that this happened in such
an organized fashion without the crown
press as do Pompeo and mattis
I have great respect for them I would
imagine if they were democratic in a
Democratic administration I would be all
over them for being in the pocket of
Saudi Arabia but since I have such
respect for them I'm going to assume
that they're being good soldiers and
when they look at the analysis they're
being technical in their statement in a
way it's refreshing right I mean
understand what Lindsey Graham is saying
here Graham says that on the facts just
doing a an analysis of the facts
he should be slamming Pompeo and mattis
for saying something that clearly
directly contradicts what he has been
convinced by by the CIA and Gina Haspel
but he's saying but I'm a Republican and
they're Republicans and were part of a
Republican administration so I'm gonna
give them a benefit of the doubt and
there must be some way I guess that in a
technical sense the CIA assessment is
accurate but Pompeo and mattis are also
being honest that is really something
else and it's outrageous that he thinks
this he's admitting that he cares about
party over facts feelings over facts or
political a nine alignment over facts
but in a sense it's so brilliant Pat
because he's figured out how to have it
both ways
the CIA briefing is clear it's
unequivocal about Mohammed bin Salman
involvement in the killing of Jamal
khashoggi but he also is going to assume
that Pompeo and mattis using some other
standard I guess are technically correct
in an arbitrary precise and narrow
technical sense it's genius in some way
right it's party over a principle which
is common amongst many politicians but
at least in this case he's being honest
I mean I think this is just who Lindsey
Graham is last year he talked about how
if Trump fired Jeff Sessions that there
would be hell to pay and then when he
actually did get around to firing Jeff
Sessions what did Lindsey Graham do
pretty much nothing he said that he
would work to find a replacement for him
and get Matt Whittaker approved so this
is Lindsey Graham for you
does he get some credit for being honest
about his horrible hypocrisy or do we
slam him because he's such a partisan
hypocrite can consider the range of
opinion now reporter Katelyn Collins
pointed this out in a good tweet
yesterday Trump said about the killing
of Jamal Kokoschka Shoji notice how I've
updated my pronunciation now Khashoggi
Trump said it could have been anybody I
mean it could be anybody almost like
that there's seven billion people on the
planet literally anyone could have done
it Jim Madison Mike Pompeo say well we
don't have any direct evidence there's
no real smoking gun here that it was
Mohammed bin Salman Lindsey Graham says
oh there's more than a smoking gun
there's a smoking saw like we literally
know what they used in order to do the
killing and then bob Corker also a
Republican mind you says that if you put
the evidence in front of a jury Mohammed
bin Salman would be convicted within a
half hour of the killing of journalist
John Malkovich meanwhile you've got John
Bolton the National Security Advisor who
refuses to listen to the audio of the
killing because he doesn't speak Arabic
so this is just Republicans Democrats
mostly just seemed to trust the evidence
in the investigation that Mohammed bin
Salman was involved send me your
thoughts specifically about why you
believe Republicans can't get on the
same page about this is it political
posturing is it that they mostly are on
the same page but they want to be
careful not to anger Trump is it
something else I want to hear from you
you can let us know on any of our
platforms including on Instagram where
the david pakman show is at david pakman
show while you're there follow me as
well i'm on instagram at david pakman we
will take a quick break and be back with
the conclusion to my interview with
economist Steven Pearlstein next one of
the day's sponsors is privacy comm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit
cards that are linked directly to your
bank account and you use those virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
which protects your actual debit card so
that it's not spread all over the
Internet and one of the best things
about it is how their mobile app and
browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a david pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy comm icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link